you have a few announcements to make I'm
going to first Stacey Arneson branch
chief at the disaster information
management research center to give us an
update on a few things
Stacey thanks Siobhan I just want to say
that of course our thoughts are with all
of those who've been affected by
hurricane Florence and Michael recently
and it's typical we have a wealth of
information on these topics but the
storms flooding and associated risks and
issues following these kinds of events
such as coping with disasters behavioral
mental health issues this year we worked
closely with the
southeast Atlantic region medical
library regional medical library to
compile information and to send it out
in multiple venues to reach as many
audience as possible the southeast
Atlantic region also worked with local
partners to check on the status and the
needs of libraries in the region as an
11 I just want to say that I'm very
excited about Lisa federer's caucus
Mozilla lemons getting much more
involved in open data and data science I
think it'll be exciting to hear what
Lisa has to say to all of us and I also
think it will be a nice add-on to our
last presentation from our Associate
Fellow in Nicole Strayhorn who talked a
little bit about open data in public
health emergency focusing on Zika for
those of you who would sit back seeing
that and it's not it is archived on our
website so that you can watch that as
well so thank you very much Savan and
Lisa and I'll turn it back over to to
Jen or to Siobhan so if we have Jen can
give us an update on wiser
hi everyone I just wanted to update you
a little bit on why there is new release
we actually have released wiser by
version 5.2 which has the chemical
intelligence tool the chemin de
intelligence tool version 2.0 which adds
three new
Toxie drones to it so we have irritant
gas opioid syndrome and convulsive
syndrome and there as well
and we also have added some globally
harmonized system or GHS classifications
to that including some of the icons so
look out for the new versions there and
I will put away me in the chapter that I
did that for you while you were talking
okay and I forgot to introduce myself
I'm Siobhan champ blackwell so but I am
going to now said if you can give Lisa
control and we're going to turn this
over to Lisa Federer and we're all
really excited to hear what Lisa has to
say so go ahead Lisa thanks so much let
me just share my screen here
hopefully you can see my slides at this
point so I just wanted to start off by
thanking different for having me to
present in this session today my name is
Lisa Thurber
I am the data science and open science
librarian at the National Library of
Medicine and this is a new position for
me I've just started here about a month
ago and I'm really excited to be able to
share some of my experience working with
data and data science with all of you so
let's get started so as an overview for
today's session I want to talk a little
bit about the sort of background of this
why is wired data management and sharing
something that should be considered in
the context of disaster and public
health and epidemic kind of information
and then once we covered that I'd like
to talk a little bit about
considerations for thinking about
disaster data looking at some case
studies of what has and has not worked
well and give you some practical advice
for thinking about how to prepare moving
forward and then there will be time for
questions at the end you can feel free
to type those in the chat box throughout
this session and I'll be answering them
for you at the end so it's a dive right
in a little bit of background so I come
from the research world really I have
been working for the last about seven
years with researchers on their data
management and variant data sharing so
there's a few things that apply here
that I think have sort of driven data
sharing in this context one is that
there are a number of funders that now
have policies requiring data sharing the
National Science Foundation has had a
policy that requires all grant proposals
to include a data management plan since
2012 the NIH has recently instituted
several data management plans and as a
matter of fact right now there is out
for public comment requests for
information on a new data management and
sharing policy that would apply for all
NIH funded grant contracts and NIH
intramural research so there's a lot of
interest in making sure that the data
that's collected as part of you know
scientific research is made available
for people for a number of reasons this
is just sort of you know good
transparent science there's a lot of use
and being able to reuse and reanalyze
data for new purposes and so this is
something that funders are interested in
number of journals have also started to
have policies that require that if
you're going to publish in their journal
your data have to be made publicly
available so as a result in you know
again the research world there's been a
very big shift towards people making
their data publicly available in
repositories and through other means
rather than just keeping it private to
their lab so this I think is kind of
going to start being extended to more of
the disaster and Public Health kind of
world particularly as we see some of
these new epidemics breaking out there
of course was Zika and Ebola and out of
those outbreaks there has been this
joint statement on data sharing that you
can see at the links below
and there are 57 signatories to this
statement on data sharing including oh I
see that someone's having some
difficulty with hearing me is is
everyone able to hear me okay
okay I'm just gonna I can I can hear you
so okay maybe it's just I can hear you
but your talker than Siobhan so maybe
you can speak up just a little bit okay
I will try thank you
so 57 signatories to this joint
statement on data sharing that include
journals as well as funders and some of
these are ones that if you're here in
the United States you're probably
familiar with the CDC the NIH and
several of the large journal publishers
as well so the journals that are
signatories to this agreement have
agreed that they will make all content
concerning the so let me see if I can
adjust my volume at all I see that there
are several people having some issues
here let's see one moment okay is that
better hopefully
turned my mic volume up so hopefully
people are able to hear me a little bit
better now okay yay all right sorry
about that
so joint statement on data sharing so as
I was saying the journals that have
signed on to this have agreed to make
all content concerning specifically in
this case the Zika virus free to access
so open access from the start no embargo
period they have also agreed that any
data or preprint that are deposited for
unrestricted dissemination ahead of the
submission will not preclude anyone from
publishing in this journey in any of
these journals so if I you know publish
anything ahead of a journal I can still
go ahead and submit that article for
publication and journals as we'll talk
about a little later in the session
rapid publication and dissemination of
this information is often very important
the funders that have signed on to this
have agreed that they will require
researchers who are doing work relevant
to any sort of public health emergency
to put in place a mechanism to share the
interim data what they're collecting as
they go as long as it is of a
you know certain quality as well as the
final data and they are agreeing to do
this as rapidly and widely as possible
and working with relevant public health
funders research communities as well as
the World Health Organization so it's a
pretty important I think commitment that
these funders and journals are making to
ensure that the data that's collected on
these public health emergencies is
getting out so that we can advance the
science on these very you know serious
issues as quickly as possible so what
type of data are we talking about you
know the joint statement that I just
mentioned is very specific to a
particular kind of data but I want to
cast that net a little bit more broadly
in today's session to talk not just
about some of the data related to these
outbreaks and epidemics but also to
other types of disasters that that you
might be working with so I'm thinking
here about data collected during a
disaster or epidemic as well as
previously collected data that will be
needed during a disaster so for example
if we have a flood situation going on we
will probably need to have information
about you know where that flooding is
likely likely to occur based on you know
the geography of that area so these are
both things to be keeping in mind as
we're thinking about all of this these
data are useful for a number of purposes
one is for detection and tracking where
is this disaster or you know incident
occurring how serious is it hopefully
some you know early detection of things
that we can put a stop to something
before it becomes too serious
coordination and response are also going
to be affected by having some of this
data available so figuring out where
interventions need to be deployed who is
working on things coordinating with
various organizations organizations when
that is relevant also really important
is assessing the effectiveness of
interventions partly for the
a you know specific disaster but also
again for having information for the
next time for you know improving when
such a thing occurs again so is there
you know a vaccine that's working is
there a quarantine procedure or whatever
it might be that we can collect data on
to assess the effectiveness of that and
then again sort of thinking ahead to
after the data that we've collected
during an incident can be used for
improving early prediction and
forecasting of potential future events I
thought this was really interesting the
image on the left I'm sure we've all
seen the images of the the cone of
uncertainty for where a hurricane will
hit and it's really pretty striking to
see how much more you know sort of
certain that forecasting has become
based on improvement in technology and
forecasting in the years since Hurricane
Katrina in 2005 so that's sort of the
you know what we're thinking about and
why we're thinking about it and I want
to sort of frame this conversation
around these four points around disaster
data and these are adapted from an
article that I think is really useful
for thinking about collecting data in
these sorts of disasters and Public
Health and outbreak kinds of situations
which you can see a citation for at the
bottom of the screen this one was sort
of findings and reflections based on
their experience with working with the
Ebola outbreak so the for sort of things
that we're going to think about here are
first of all collecting the data that we
need how are we going to make sure that
we're collecting all of the relevant
data and in the right form we're going
to talk about how to optimize data
quality to make sure that not only are
we collecting the the data that we need
but that it's in a form that the
relevant stakeholders will be able to
use it we'll talk a little bit about
ensuring adequate data availability so
how do we make sure that again that data
is able to get disseminated to the
who need it and then finally looking at
reporting the results of various
analyses this would probably be
something that comes a little later down
the line but these are also you know
things that we should be considering as
we prepare for this type of data of
management and sharing of this kind of
data so I want to start first with
collecting the relevant data so the
article that I just mentioned
specifically deals with outbreak kinds
of data and they identify three
different levels of data that should be
collected again this is specific to
outbreaks but I think you could kind of
you know see how this would also make
sense in the context of other disasters
as well so one would be the individual
level so individual cases of illness or
in the case of other types of disasters
individual you know homes that may be
affected or families that may be
affected so looking you know very
specifically at this individual level
relevant in the case of outbreak kinds
of disasters the exposure level data is
important as well so looking at
transmission between individuals looking
potentially at transmission from you
know food sources or environmental
sources so that we're able to figure out
how transmission occurs and of course
then how to stop a quart a lip and then
population level data as well so how
does the population as a whole affected
and I also really like they refer to
this as metadata as well so there are
some things that are sort of again that
existing information that we bring into
the context of a disaster that again you
can kind of think of as metadata so the
things like you know how are people in
this population distributed where are
there large groups of people or where
are there roads that would be useful to
be able to transport you know supplies
where are there other than those things
that you know the the land is lower so
they'll be likely to flood so that
information that's already there and
collected that we will need to know to
inform response
so you know again I say that I come from
the world of research and I think that
you know there's obviously a lot of
different kinds of research data but I
think there's even more kinds of data
when we're talking about the sort of
disaster related information and it's
not necessarily the data that you might
think a lot of this information can come
from sort of non-traditional sources
there have been a number of articles
that have looked at how Twitter can be
used to you know track information and
you know track sort of response to
various disasters at the end of the
slides I have a link to some sort of
recommended resources and there's an
article there by one of my former
colleagues from the NIH library or
Alicia's a co-author on it Alicia
Levinsky that is a really interesting
use of Twitter for looking at disaster
information and you can see from this
that you know not everything is going to
be useful a you know the third highest
amount of tweets in relation to
Hurricane sandy was jokes that he'll
probably not terribly useful but again
this data can actually be a really
useful real-time source of data for for
disasters crowdsourcing can also be a
interesting and sort of different way to
collect some data
most of us or many of us these days have
you know these cells a smartphones that
are actually very sophisticated data
collection devices in many cases and you
know where that access is available that
can be an important source of
information for collecting data and
responding
so I want to talk next about how to
collect quality data we can get a lot of
data collect a lot of information but
how are we going to make sure that it's
useful for the people who would be able
to analyze it and get something out of
it so one important consideration I
think is how will data be digitized I
think especially in the case of when
we're looking at you know disasters or
outbreaks often there might not be power
you know people might be collecting
information and data in an analog form
writing it down
you know however they're collecting it
but consideration needs to be taken in
advance so how that data will be
digitized so that it can get distributed
both in the moments to first responders
and others who might need it but also
long-term if we're going to be able to
use this data to you know get something
out of this information to be able to do
research to be able to draw conclusions
that data will need to be in some sort
of digital form so again important to
think about how that data will be
digitized and you know turned into a
form that can be used beyond just in the
moment here's how we are going to
respond
so as as we're thinking about
digitization one of the things that's
really important is picking the right
format there are obviously lots of
different you know types of files and
types of data that we can save I've
highlighted a few very popular and good
for data analysis formats here so plain
text files really useful CSV files which
are comma separated value files are you
know an excellent way to store any sort
of tabular data that you might have like
in a spreadsheet XML JSON these are all
sort of organized data formats that are
useful and they're open formats so we
don't necessarily have to use a
particular program to open these files
some of this data that we're talking
about in this context might be
geographic data or geospatial data I am
NOT a GIS expert but there's a lot of
information available about collecting
this type of data and there are some
very standard file formats that are used
shape files for example are sort of how
the existing information about the
geography is conveyed and then you can
overlay layers on top of that so these
are things that might be useful I do
want to point out that's PDF and stuff
like Word docs not data so I worked with
a lot of data scientists and I was
having a conversation with one of them
the other day about data.gov and they
were like it's a great resource and it's
very cool but a lot of the data is in a
PDF and that is not data that's not
something I can use so think ahead about
what formats will be useful for saving
that data and for sharing it and making
sure that people can do meaningful
analysis with it
so I spoke a little bit about data
scientists and how they work with data
obviously not everyone who works with
the type of data that might be collected
or used during a disaster would be a
data scientist but I think that it's
useful to think about sort of the best
practices for data science because these
are applicable across the board and if
you have this data in a format that data
scientists can use they will likely be
interested in analyzing your problem so
I like to point to this as a really good
example of a community that has
developed a really useful data resource
in a format that a data scientist would
be able to use there are several
different programming languages that
data scientists will often use one of
them that's very popular is R and this
malaria Atlas is in our package so
basically it's like an app or sort of an
add-on for R that can be used to allow a
user to download visualize and
manipulate this data about malaria so
it's super easy then for a data
scientist or anyone who wishes to
analyze this data to not only find the
data but to get it in a format that
works for them and she'd be able to just
very quickly and without a whole lot of
trouble be able to analyze it so again I
think this is a really interesting
example and I think it would be really
useful for other communities collecting
data that they would hope to have some
analysis put to to think about how to
get that data out to the community in a
form that can be used
so I also wanted to mention a data
harmonization and this is basically the
process of taking data from multiple
different sources and getting them all
into sort of a way that they can talk to
each other this can involve formats we
already talked about you know the fact
that there are different file formats
that don't always talk to each other
very easily this could also involve
variables measures and inputs so
particularly particularly when we're
talking about something that's happening
say in an international context or on a
large geographic scale you might have
multiple different people from different
groups pulling together data and they're
not necessarily going to be doing it in
the same way so for example I might be
recording you know the height of
something in feet whereas somebody else
might be recording it in meters I might
be using a CSV file whereas somebody
else is using an excel file so thinking
about how all of that data can be pulled
together from multiple different sources
is really useful to ensure that you
don't just have these little silos of
data that you can really pull everything
together and again have those more
meaningful analyses based on a more rich
and robust data set so this obviously is
something that you would probably need
to think about in advance to make some
plans for there are a number of
different ways to approach data
harmonization one that I will draw
attention to is common data elements or
CDEs just because the CDE repository is
hosted here at NLM so common data
elements are basically these forms that
are created in different sort of
disciplines or areas or to measure
specific things that are sort of a set
way of collecting and recording
information so you know here is an
example of one very simple common data
element form so you can see that you
know very specifically we have that the
date of birth is going to be recorded in
month day and year you could think that
you know if we were working with an
international collaborator
a lot of them might be recording things
in a different form like in Europe they
put I think the day first and then the
month other places might list the year
first so here we have a very
well-defined you know way that we're
going to record this information the age
that would be you can kind of see it's a
scroll thing so we would have a set
number of items that we can choose from
same thing with these radio buttons for
gender and a hispanic latino background
so you can see that this sort of
constrains the way that we collect data
and ensures that everyone you know
regardless of how big of a group of
people were using to collect data no
matter where they are everyone's going
to be collecting things sort of on the
same page and that ensures that we'll
have a good high-quality data set that
we can use and analyze without too much
cleaning or having to think about how we
can get those things to work together so
i want to move now to how we ensure data
availability and again this partly
refers to both how we are collecting
data in the you know at the time of a
disaster but also ensuring that when a
disaster occurs we will have access to
the data that we need in order to
respond to it so part of this has to do
with you know sort of best practices for
data preservation part of that is data
redundancy there's an acronym locks lots
of copies keep stuff safe so you can
imagine that you know if we have a very
important data set and we have it stored
you know maybe I have it saved on my
computer and I'm here in this building
obviously that is not going to be very
helpful in terms of ensuring
preservation of that data if my computer
crashes that data is lost if you know I
if I lose my computer that data is gone
lots of things could happen if we only
have one copy of a file so it stands to
reason that okay let's make a backup
copy maybe I have an external hard drive
that sits here on my desk at home on my
laptop computer I
you know my file saved and I have an
external hard drive that's great I'm
backing up but those are all in my
building what if my building catches on
fire or you know there's a flood or
whatever might happen I could have a
million copies of my data but if they're
all in the same location it's gonna be
lost anyway
so having not only multiple copies of
data but multiple area or you know
locations to physically store that data
ensures that we will have access to the
data regardless of what happens you know
in a given location unfortunately you
know now we have the option to have
reasonably cheap and reliable cloud
storage so it's very possible to you
know store your data somewhere locally
and also have it living in the cloud
where it is going to be backed up and
you know of course there are instances
where cloud storage has failed but it's
typically a pretty safe way to ensure a
backup of your data there's also this
rule of three for preservation so the
idea is that you want to have at least
three copies of a file and those should
be on at least two different types of
media
these are I've borrowed this image is
from a previous presentation that I did
many years ago and like it's already
outdated you would probably not be
storing data on a CD but so you know
maybe a harddrive backup plus the one
that's on your computer
cloud storage plus one Madonna you know
part flash drive or whatever it might be
so choosing the the you know two
different media that are most useful to
you in your particular setting and then
at least one of those copies should be
kept off-site so again cloud storage can
be a really effective way of handling
this especially since it also has the
advantage of allowing people from
multiple different locations to access
data at any given time
one way of handling data preservation
and access that has a number of
advantages is storing that data in some
sort of repository so a repository will
be useful because for one thing the
preservation is sort of taken care of
for you
when you give your data over to those
repositories they are going to you know
take on the responsibility of preserving
the data and storing it and this also
has the benefit of making the data in
most cases publicly available to other
you know researchers or first responders
or other you know whoever it is that
might need this data I'll mention at the
end a couple of sort of disaster
specific repositories but a couple of
resources that are useful for finding a
relevant repository the first one we
three data stands for the registry of
research data repositories and that is
basically like a catalog of subject
specific data repositories so you can
put in you know the type of data that
you're interested in or the you know
subject matter or whatever it might be
and this will help you locate a
repository that houses that kind of data
the National Library of Medicine also
hosts a list of NIH data sharing
repositories
these are repositories that are in most
cases administered by one of the 27
Institute's of the National Institutes
of Health or else they're in some way
endorsed by one of those Institute's so
most of those are fairly subject
specific around the you know types of
research that those different
Institute's are funding but that can be
a useful place to locate repositories
that could be relevant as well so this
is you know something that I think is
useful to think about in advance you
know where might we put data in the case
of an emergency or where would we find
data that we might need in the case of
an emergency and again something that's
useful to think about in advance I think
a lot of researchers that I work with
don't necessarily think about this when
they're collecting data and so then when
it comes time to share
they really don't know where to put it
and I can imagine that that would be
even more challenging in the context of
something like you know a disaster where
time is really of the essence and you
don't have time to be you know googling
around trying to find a repository
another thing to consider is licensing
if we're going to try to get data out
there to you know be analyzed and to
share it with the community and make
sure that everyone who needs it has
access to it we also need to think about
how we're going to license that data so
there are a number of licenses that
allow you to you know very specifically
indicate that you are making this data
available for others to use in various
different ways so I've given links to
several of them here Creative Commons is
one that is very popular and that you
may have heard of but there's also these
other ones that are specific to data
some of these are basically licenses
that allow you to place your data
entirely in the public domain others of
them allow you to have some restrictions
so some of those common features of
restrictions that you might wish to put
on your license one is that it can be
reused but only with attribution so if
someone plans to reuse or modify or
remix this or publish on it or whatever
they can do so but they have to give
credit to the original author or creator
another sort of way that you can sort of
limit the licensing is with the share
alike clause that most of these licenses
have so this allows people to modify if
they like to share the data or the
object that's in question but any
derivatives have to have the same
license as the original so if I take
your data and I say combine it with
another data set I can't like sell it
for profit I have to share it using the
same license that the data set
originally had to start with and then
you can also specify that the data or
object can only
used for non-commercial purposes so I
can't take the data and develop a
commercial product that I sell and make
money off of so again these different
licenses you know depending on the type
of data or what you would want people to
be able to do with it you know may have
these different features that would be
relevant to you but even if you're
really wanting to make data completely
open it's useful to explicitly label it
as such because if you don't then
there's really no way of people for
people to know that they can use it or
how they can use it so at the very least
use one of those you know public domain
sorts of licenses so that people know
that this data is open and available
all right so next I want to talk about
analyzing and reporting the results so
we've got data we've got it collected
how do we get that information out so
I've mentioned several times that you
know in the come from this research
world and so I'm very familiar with you
know the journal publication process and
that typically would not be super useful
in the case of disasters the you know I
think the Joint signatory thing that I
mentioned earlier the joint agreement
about open access to data and articles
is a good example of this you know if we
had written a paper on Ebola or Zika and
submitted it to a journal it can take
months if not years for that to actually
appear in print and by then it's really
too late so you know important to think
about how to get this information out
quickly so I've mentioned repositories
those can be repositories for data as
well as things like the Open Science
framework which I had a link to this on
the slide but I apologize I haven't
included the link here the Open Science
framework is basically a forum for
sharing not just data but also things
like code used to analyze the data
images you know articles that go with it
so you can get a lot of information out
very easily and it's all open for people
to use another way that can be useful to
disseminate information is through
preprint servers archive is just one
there are several that are more subject
specific but these allow for quick
posting of articles and what's also kind
of nice comment on those articles so the
community can interact with that and the
authors can see that so if I have some
really important information that I want
to get out quickly I can put that on a
preprint server one of the other things
that's kind of nice as that joint
declaration stated preprints don't
necessarily count as prior publication
so if I am someone who's collecting data
and you know I want to get the
information out quickly
but I'm also a researcher and I want to
be able to get academic credit for
publishing my article in a really
important journal like nature that
doesn't necessarily preclude me from
doing so
so preprint servers are useful way of
getting information out on a very rapid
basis it's also important to consider
though that rapid reporting should not
we should not substitute you know
high-quality reporting for this so you
want to get information out but you want
to make sure that it is correct that it
is undergone quality control that it's
in you know there's proper format but
it's harmonized so rapid yes but correct
as well
so another piece to think about is
responsible reporting so some types of
data that would be collected in
instances like this could fall under the
common rule or other regulations that
apply to human research subjects so you
know we have to think about if we are
collecting data on patients or on humans
how do we report that responsibly and
still ensure that their privacy is
maintained and that you know we don't
put out personal health information or
other sensitive information about
individuals it's also important to think
about sort of ethically what should we
report about certain things this is a
link to an article that was a pretty
controversial when it came out this was
a study that looked at mutating the
avian flu virus to be able to be
transmissible between mammals and there
was a lot of controversy again when this
was first well before it was published
when it was accepted for publication
because it sort of made it possible then
like you know now we would know how to
potentially mutate this to make this
transmissible between humans and are
there ways that for example terrorists
could use that information to be able to
create some sort of you know bio weapon
and so we need to think about how to
convey information in a way that will
get the information to the people who
need it but also again maintain privacy
and you know ensure that people who
don't need access to that information
don't get it
another issue to consider is giving
credit where credit is due so you know
we are talking about things where you
know you're probably collecting a lot of
information in in the moment and you're
not necessarily thinking about like oh I
want to make sure that I can put this on
my CV for tenure but that kind of thing
is actually important in some cases here
again is I apologize if I got to put the
link on this one too
we went to an article about another
controversy controversy around using
shared data in this case again the flu
virus so there's a flu repository called
GI s AI D and you know people can put
information about flu genome in there
and so this Chinese group put that
information in someone else published on
it and did it credit them in the way
that they wanted to be credited and so
that became a bit of a controversy so
again when we're talking about anything
that sort of involved especially
scholarly publication it's important to
make sure that if we're going to reuse
data we're doing so with respect to the
creator or author who collected it so
I've included links here to a couple of
resources for data citation one is data
cite this is an international
organization that facilitates
access to data by assigning a digital
object identifier to data or do is so
having a DOI allows for for one thing
for persistence so we know that whenever
we want to access this data we can go to
the DOI and we'll be able to find it
even if it's moved you know where it's
stored on the internet it's also unique
identifier so we can be able to point
specifically to a certain data set or
even you know a certain subset of a data
set depending on how with what
granularity they have assigned those do
is and most importantly in this case it
allows us to be able to cite that data
set so that for one thing we're giving
credit to the group or person who
collected that data but also it allows
other
people who maybe like are reading my
article to be able to easily go back and
find that dataset as well the second
link here is to force eleven data
citation principles this is a list of
eight principles for data citation
there's sort of more high-level than the
data cite piece but it's useful for
thinking about in terms of how do we
want to be able to give credit to people
how do we want to be able to track data
so that's something I think interesting
to be thinking about as well so I've
covered a lot of sort of high-level
things here but I wanted to you know
sort of move on to a little bit more
practical piece now and that is what can
we be doing now to prepare you know as I
said before as I'm sure all of you know
pre-planning and preparation is super
important because you know at the time a
disaster occurs it's really too late to
be thinking about some of these things
so one of the things that I think is
important is really just thinking about
what kind of data will we need to
collect how are we gonna collect it how
are we gonna store it how are we gonna
share it so some of these practical
pieces to think about I you know most
people that are collecting the type of
research or the type of data that we're
talking about here wouldn't have to
write a data management plan but I think
that these data management planning
types of things are actually really
useful for just providing a kind of a
framework for thinking about things so
these data management plans are as I
mentioned earlier in the session
required by some funders so if you are
going to require if you're going to
apply for a grant you have to submit a
data management plan again that's
probably you know there won't be such a
requirement for the types of data that
would be you know within the purview of
what we're talking about here but again
it's sort of a nice structured way to
think about what would we need to be
aware of so things that you might not
necessarily think of our sort of
outlined here so I've listed to the DMP
tool is one that is out of the
California digital life
along with some of their partners and it
has a number of US funders so templates
and sort of interactive way to build a
DMP that would meet the requirements of
various US funders but again just sort
of you know even if you don't have to
submit one to a funder just a useful way
to sort of get some ideas to think
through and then this other one the DCC
checklist for a data management plan is
from the digital curation center in the
UK this one is a really really long
checklist so it might look a little bit
overwhelming there are like I think
several hundred items on there now all
of them obviously will apply but again
just sort of a useful framework for
thinking about you know what Mike what
considerations might we need to you know
be keeping in mind as we do this so you
know if you're if this is sort of the
first time that you thought about data
management and sharing or if you're
working with groups who have not been
used to thinking about this before these
can be really helpful ways to ensure
that you're really sort of checking all
the bases and preparing everything that
you might need
another really important piece is
developing that infrastructure for
getting data out for sharing it again by
the time you know things are going on
it's too late to think about we want to
make sure that everyone knows in advance
where we're gonna put data and where we
can find that data so here again I
mentioned earlier that these are sort of
specific to disaster clients of data the
humanitarian data exchange has as you
can see here a very large number of data
sets not all of them are necessarily
related to like disaster information
there are other sorts of you know
humanitarian crises that they have data
on but there's a lot of really
interesting and useful data here one of
the other things about this is that
pretty much anyone can access the data
but you have to be an approved
organization to be able to upload the
data so you can you know sort of trust
that the data here is going to be
authoritative and correct and it comes
from a vetted source so you know if
you're working with the type of data
that would fit in here for example I
know that they host some Ebola and Zika
data it would be worth perhaps thinking
about becoming one of those approved
organizations so that you know if the
event happens that you do have data that
you've collected and want to share this
is a way you can quickly and easily do
so and again you know share that to the
community so that they know where to
find it
FEMA has a number of different data
resources which you can find on their
website and this one in particular I
thought was interesting it's GIS data so
you know geospatial data about specific
emergency management and disaster
situations so that can be useful if
you're looking for or wanting to share
that kind of data as well
so I I'm entered this training and
outreach how do we ensure that everyone
knows the plan I had to include this dog
on the slide I don't think he's training
for data collection during disaster but
he is very cool and he was training for
Disaster Response so again sort of
communicating to the community both the
people who would be collecting data as
well as the people who would need to use
that data so that we all know in advance
what the plan is just the same as we do
fire drills so we know when we leave the
building where we should go and find you
know everyone so we ensure that no one
has been left behind it should be you
know included in this sort of
pre-planning and training to prepare for
these sorts of things that we consider
you know again how we're gonna collect
data where we're gonna put it what the
plan is so as I said I've included some
additional reading here just to sort of
quickly walk you through this the first
one is a really interesting background
briefing for the World Health
Organization on preparation for thinking
about data and results sharing during
public health emergencies it's brief but
it does a really good job of introducing
some of the challenges and barriers as
well as ways of overcoming those
challenges and barriers the next one is
sort of a more general piece that looks
at how can we make this you know data
sharing sort of part of the way that we
just think about responding to public
health emergencies the third one is that
article that I mentioned earlier that I
think is a really really useful article
not only for thinking about outbreak do
that or outbreak data collection but
just sort of generally disaster
information the second last one is that
example that I mentioned of using
Twitter as a way of collecting
information for sort of surveillance
during a disaster and then the bottom
one is an article that has to do with
that sort of responsible reporting piece
that I mentioned how do we make sure
that we share data
but we do so in a way that is going to
be responsible and ensure that you know
it sort of doesn't fall into the wrong
hands
so that's wrapped up everything I had
for you my contact info is here I am on
Twitter I tweet a lot about data and
also my dog so you can reach in there
and I'm happy to take any questions that
you have at this point Wow
thank you Lisa that was just so that was
just amazing if you covered so much
material and we really appreciate it
just just so the people on the call know
we do post your powerpoints and the
recording of this webinar to our website
we will also pull out all of these links
and create a handout so that people can
have a handout of all of the resources
that you shared not having to go into
the PowerPoint to get them so I know
Jen's been monitoring questions as well
as filling in so much information in the
chat box Jen do you have questions that
people put into the chat box or Lisa
then maybe you're needed if you're
talking alright yes I love thanks Alison
about what what about backup systems
like Fox or the cloud yeah that's an
excellent point
so having data stored on some sort of
cloud search system is an excellent way
to ensure that you know even if if
something you know but Falls your your
physical data on your computer or
whatever you will still have that data
backed up in some cases if you're
collecting any sort of human data or you
know human subjects data anything that
might be private not all of those are
HIPAA compliant so if that does apply to
you you would need to think about you
know sort of vetting the source that you
use but I know that box comm does have
I'm not sure if it's like by default but
I know that it is possible to have the
sort of level of security for that that
you know ensures that it's HIPAA
compliant and I'd like like I said that
other that nice thing about that is that
if you have data on the cloud people can
access it from pretty much anywhere you
know just in my my personal case I am
currently working on my doctoral
dissertation and I sometimes work in my
office and I sometimes work on my laptop
at home
and it's kind of annoying to have to
like email myself those files but I save
it you know in the cloud and that way
wherever I am I can access the most
current version so yeah those are great
solutions for a number of different
reasons yeah
Thanks I don't have any other questions
just now if anyone else would like to
ask Lisa our questions please go ahead
and type it into the chat box right now
on do you have anything else well I just
know that that we're all trying to
figure out what role libraries play in
in this helping researchers and
scientists with the organization of data
and around the topic of disasters and
public health emergencies so excuse us a
lot to think about yeah and I think the
audience and other information
professionals really can have an
important role in this this is something
that you know sort of the the library
community or at least the academic
library and Health Science Library
community has really started to think
about this you know sort of data piece
and so you know I think that in many
cases probably you know the communities
that you might be working with haven't
really thought about this and I don't
imagine that that's been communicated to
them in the same way that it has to
researchers and so I think you know this
is a great opportunity for librarians
and and others to sort of bring these
best practices in for groups who might
not be thinking about it
okay well I don't see any more questions
and we're getting close to the end of
the hour so thanks so much everyone
again you have Lisa's contact
information Lisa can you hand the ball
back to me I do want to talk about how
to
here we go oh I thought it was I know
what it is it's the next slide there we
go
if you if you want to get MLA seee
credits for this class you need to take
the survey and I think Jen's going to
put the information about this the links
into the chat box so you can fill out
the survey and then log on to the
Medical Library Association website
they're a learning management system and
enter the code e is data and then you'll
get your MLA c e will be adding the
recording the slides and a handout on to
our webinars page and we have an idea
for our November meeting although we
have to contact all of the speakers so
we hope to be back again in November
with the call and then take a break for
the end of the year so thanks to
everybody for joining us thank you so
much Lisa for your content and your
wisdom and we'll see you all again in a
month hang on just one second Siobhan
don't have one more question yes you
can't see because it was sent privately
so there's a gentleman here who says if
I have files on my computer on a secure
flash drive and on the county server
does that satisfy the rule of three does
the county server count as a third
storage location
yes so I would say likely assuming that
that County storage is not like
physically located in the same place
they are offices yeah that would that
would satisfy the rule of three for sure
right thanks
okay now we'll say so long and we'll see
you all again in a month thank you